Yo sólo quiero decir, en los ultimos años yo he
tenido la oportunidad de realizar esta conferencia de cierre
Y he tenido algunos actos de calentamiento
Hace 8 años
Billy Graham fue el telonero para mi
y pense que eso era--
(risas)
Y pense que no habia una manera en absoluto
(en el infierno) de superar eso
pero solo quiero decir
y lo digo sin alguna ironia,
pienso que hablo por parte de todos en el auditorio
cuando digo que deseo a dios que usted fuera el presidente de los Estados Unidos
(aplausos)
Okey, este es el titulo de mi charla hoy
"Un consumo agonico hacia la muerte"
Solo quiero darles un vistazo rapido
primero que todo por favor recuerde que soy políticamente correcto
y lo digo todo con gran afecto
si alguno de ustedes tiene estomago sensible o se siente mareado
ahora es el momento de revisar su Blackberry.
(risas)
solo para revisar, esta es mi charla TED.
vamos a hacer unas bromas,
Algunos chistes,
algunas parodias,
y luego hablaremos acerca del punto L1
(risas)
Entonces, una de las preguntas que me hago a mi mismo
si este fue el evento TED más preocupante?
Revisemos algunos cosas que se dijeron,
Imagenes de regeneracion del higado
Caras llenas con viruela:
21% de la conferencia
(risas)
Menciones a osos polares ahogandose, 4 %
imagenes de la tierra desapareciendose por inundacion o gripe aviar: 64 %
(risas)
Y David Pogue cantando sus músicas.
(aplausos)
Debido a que este es el evento TED mas preocupante,
He estado trabajando con Neils Gershenfeld en el morral TED del proximo año.
Y si --Y si la conferencia está siquiera cerca de ser tan preocupante--
entonces, tendremos un morral para gritar el proximo año.
(risas)
Va a ser un morral de viruela a viruela para gritar, claro esta.
Por lo que se veran de esta manera.
(risas)
Si lo traemos a este lado
y lo abrimos , Aaaaaaaah!
(risas)
Mientras tanto retornando a la Universidad TED,
Esta mujer encantadora está enseñando como to cortar patatas fritas,
(risas)
Asi que Robert Wright, yo no sé,
sentí que si existe alguien a quien Helen necesitaba dar antidepresivos
sería él.
Yo quiero deliberadamente interferir con sus niveles de dopamina
(risas)
Él estaba hablando acerca de la moralidad.
La clase de moralidad económica es,
Queremos bombardearlo hasta que vuelva a la edad de piedra,
La clase de moralidad de negocios es,
no bombardeen a Japon -- ellos hacen mi carro.
y la moralidad de primera claes es, no bombardeen Mexico, ellos limpian mi casa.
(risas)
Si, es políticamente incorrecto.
bueno
Ahora, quiero hacer algo para ustedes,
(risas)
Bueno, ahora,
yo digo (palabras inentendibles)
(palabras inentendibles)
mumble -- aighh!
(risas)
Entonces quiero mostrarles a ustedes,
Quiero hablar acerca de una revolucionaria interfaz de computadores
que le permite trabajar con imagenes asi de facil
como si utilizara una interfaz muy natural.
(risas)
y ustedes pueden--
pueden usar movimientos muy naturales
como estos.
(aplausos)
Bueno, aqui tenemos a una profesora de Harvard,
ella es de Harvard, y yo sólo quiero mencionar y
ella es realmente una profesora de Harvard.
Ella estaba hablando acerca de 7 universos dimensionales invertidos.
Con, ustedes saben, claro, está el cerebro de gravedad.
está el cerebro débil, y está mi débil cerebro,
que es muy, muy absolutamente débil para entender
de que carajos estaba hablando ella?
(risas)
Ahora--
Una de las cosas que es muy importante para mi
es tratar de entender porque carajos estoy yo aquí.
Por esa razón salí.
y recogi un Best seller de negocios.
Ustedes saben, básicamente usa como premisa central a la mitologia griega,
y es de un hombre llamado el Pastor Rick Warren,
y se llama
"La vida conducida por el delfín"
(risas)
Y Rick es como
un dios pagano,
lo que pienso que es apropiado,
de una cierta manera,
Y ahora vamos a tener un tipo de
ahora vamos a tener un poco más de visualización acerca de Rick Warren
Ok
(risas)
Muy bien,
ahora, el rojo es Rick Warren
y El verde es Daniel Dennett , oK?
(risas)
Estas escalas son religiosidad desde de 0%,
o ateísmo, a 100%, biblicamente cierto.
y estos son los libros vendidos, en escala algorítmica
(risas)
30 mil, 300 mil, 3 millones, 30 millones, 300 millones.
ok, ahora se mueven, ahora se mueven.
(risas)
y Rick Warren comienza a tomar la delantera,comienza a tomar la delantera,
si, y su base instalada se vuelve un poco más grande.
(risas)
pero la peligrosa idea de Darwin vuelve, vuelve.
Dejenme mostrarles los senderos para que puedan ver un poco mejor
(risas)
(aplausos)
Ahora, una de las cosas que es muy importante,
Nicholas Negroponte nos comento acerca de Un lap dance por...
lo siento--
(risas)
acerca de un portátil por niño,
ahora hablemos acerca de unas características
que son importantes para este aparato revolucionario.
voy a hablarles acerca de los parametros de diseño,
y luego se los mostraré en persona.
Primero que todo, necesita ser pequeño,
se necesita que sea plano, para que sea transportable
liviano. Portable.
Que use muy poca energía.
Con altísima resolución.
que se pueda ver en la luz del dia. Que trabaje donde sea.
Y aplicable a muchas plataformas
ahora, hemos hecho alguna investigacion --
Neil Gershenfeld y los laboratorios Fab salieron al mercado.
Realizaron algo de investigación, y trajimos, lo que pensamos puede ser un prototipo perfecto
de lo que los estudiantes en el campo están pidiendo,
Y aquí está,
el computador de 100 dolares
(risas)
OK, OK, OK, OK -- excellente, excellente.
Ahora, He comprado este aparato de Cliffor Stoll por cerca de 900 dólares
y él, junto con su equipo de estudiantes secundaria
estamos realizando ciencia de verdad.
Asi que estamos intentando revisar y tratando de que se mueva aquí,
y ver quien usa marijuana.
(risas)
Y seremos capaces de encontrar algo de marijuana, Jim Young?
Sólo si abrimos los lockers suficientes,
(risas)
OK, ahora la viruela es una enfermedad extremadamente preocupante.
Tenemos al Dr. Larry Brillian hablando sobre como erradicamos la viruela.
Yo quisiera mostrarles las fases de la viruela.
Comenzamos. Con el día uno.
(risas)
Día dos
día tres, le aparece una gran erupción en su hombro.
Día tres.
Día cuatro.
(risas)
Día cinco.
y día seis.
(risas)
Ahora las buenas noticias son, porque yo soy un profesional médico entrenado,
Yo sé que a pesar de que ella quedará marcada de por vida,
ella va a tener una recuperación total.
(risas)
Ahora las buenas noticias acerca de Arquitectos por la Humanidad
es que son uno de los grupos más increíbles.
Ellos estan patrocinando una competencia de diseño
para crear unas soluciones de edificios médicos innovadores,
soluciones para clínicas, en África,
Y ellos tuvieron una competencia de diseño.
Ahora lo mas maravilloso es, Larry Brillian recientemente fue nombrado
fue nombrado como el director de la Fundación Google.
Por lo que decidió que él ayudaría--
El ayudaría el trabajo de Cameron.
Y la forma en la que decidió ayudar ese trabajo,
fue enviando cerca de 50,000 containers
de bocaditos de Google.
(risas)
Por lo que deseo mostrarles algunos prototipos,
Las Naciones Unidas, como saben, tardaron 20 años para agregarle una solapa a una tienda.
Pero pienso que tenemos cosas mas excitantes
Esta fue hecha en casa con Fruit-Roll ups
(risas)
(aplausos)
Y esas galletas con -- recubiertas de chocolate blanco
y lo realmente maravilloso de esto es,
cuando has terminado, bueno
te lo puedes comer.
Pero lo que más me emociona
es la increíble casa de granola
(risas)
Y la casa de granola con una galleta especial como techo
para recolectar agua y reciclarla.
Y es, bueno, en este lado unos "sour patch kids" normales,
Y osos de gomitas para dejar entrar la luz,
(risas)
Pero en este lado, tiene gomitas de oso azucaradas
Para difuminar la luz más tenue.
y nosotros, solo quisimos mostrarles como se vería en el sitio.
(risas)
(aplausos)
Asi que, Einstein
Einstein, dime--
¿Cuál es tu canción favorita?
no, dije ¿Cuál es tu canción favorita?
"pájaro libre"
(risas)
(aplausos)
Asi que, Einstein,
¿Cuál es tu grupo musical favorito?
¿puedes decirlo de nuevo?, ¿Cuál es tu grupo musical favorito?
ok, una vez más -- te voy a dar una pequeña ayuda
Tu grupo musical favorito -- es Diana Ross y los
Audiencia: Supremes!
Exacto
(aplausos)
¿Podemos aumentar el volumen en el portátil, por favor?
(risas)
"pájaro libre" me recuerda que si ustedes
que si escuchan "pájaro libre" al revés
esto es lo que podrían escuchar.
Computador. Satan.Satan.Satan.Satan.
Satan.Satan.Satan.
ahora, sólo quiero que entiendan todo el mensaje , asi que
(risas)
quiero ayudarles un poco más.
Computaor: My dulce Satan. Dan Dennet adora a Satan.
Compra "la vida conducida por el propósito" o Satan tomará tu alma
(risas)
Asi que,
hemos hablado acerca del calentamiento global,
pero, ustedes saben, como Jill dijo, suena un poco bonito,
buen clima en invierno, en la ciudad de Nueva York.
Y como Jay Walker dijo, esto no asusta lo suficiente,
Asi que Al, yo creería que soy bueno en el manejo de marcas.
Asi que he tratado de pensar en un buen proceso de diseño
para tener un nuevo término para "calentamiento global"
Asi que comence con Babel Fish. Busque calentamiento global
Y decidi cambiarlo de inglés a holandés,
en "Het globale Verwarmen."
de holandés a chino, en "Hordahordaneecheewa."
(risas)
Chino a portugés: Aquecer-se Global.
Después portugués a latín
(risas)
Aquecer-se ucked-fay.
y finalmente retornando al inglés
que es, "estamos totalmente jodidos"
(risas)
(aplausos)
Ahora, no sé ustedes
Pero Michael Shermer habló acerca de la voluntad de los seres humanos--
evolutivamente, están diseñados para ver patrones en las cosas
por ejemplo, en sandwiches de queso
ahora ¿pueden mirar con atención y ver a la vírgen maría?
Quiero dejárselos un poco más claro
(risas)
¿es esta la vírgen maría?
¿o es Mena Trott?
Asi que hablé con Josh Prince-Ramus acerca del centro de convenciones
y las conferencias. Se están volviendo muy grandes
se esta volviendo un poco muy grande. Esta llenándose y parece un poco más grande
Asi que traté de hacer un programa
cómo podemos reacomodar la estructura para reacomodar TED
Asi que primero que todo decidimos
(risas)
que necesitamos una tercera parte de librería,
una tercera parte para el Google cafe
20% para registro, 80% un hotel lujoso,
el 5% para los baños
y por supuesto, deseabamos tener la habitacion de emisión simultánea
el lobby y el Foro Steinbeck.
Ahora quiero mostrarles como quedó
literalmente creado en un programa de diseño
Asi que primero
uno de los problemas con Monterrey es si llegase el calentamiento global
y groenlandia se derrite como ustedes dicen, el nivel del océano
aumentara 20 pies e inundará todo el centro de convenciones
asi que vamos a construir este nuevo edificio con zancos,
asi que construimos este edificio con zancos,
asi que,
(risas)
aqui es donde pondremos el Auditorio Steinbeck
y lo maravilloso acerca de la nueva librería es
es que va a ser construida en espiral organizada por un sistema decimal de Dewey
(risas)
Luego construiremos un ascensor que te ayude a subir acá,
y finalmente colocaremos el Hotel Marriott,
y la plaza Portola en el techo.
(aplausos)
ahora, no sé ustedes, pero algunas veces tengo estas imágenes en mi cabeza,
de haber sido separado en el nacimiento,
no sé ustedes, pero cuando veo a Aubrey de Grey,
yo inmediatamente pienso en Gandalf el gris,
(risas)
ok, ahora hemos escuchado, por supuesto,
que todos somos soldados acá.
ahora lo que yo, realmente quiero que hagan ahora es,
saquen una hoja de papel. ¿todos tienen su hoja de papel en blanco?
y quiero que saquen un lápiz,
y quiero que escriban una nota terrorista.
(risas)
si sacamos a ELMO por un momento
si sacamos a ELMO por un momento, entonces sabrán
les voy a dar un modelo que pueden utilizar para trabajar, ok?
(risas)
y luego quisiera que doblen la nota en un avión de papel,
y una vez esté doblada en el avión de papel,
quiero que tomen un poco de ántrax
(risas)
y quiero que lo coloquen en el avión de papel.
Y quiero que se lo envien a Jim Young.
(risas)
Afortunadamente, Yo recibí el premio TED de este año.
y quería ver--
Y quiero dedicar esta película a mi padre, Homer
OK
Ahora la película no es lo suficientemente dura,
Asi que intente hacerla ver un poco más dura,
Asi que voy a tratar y hacer esto mientras recito Pi
(risas)
3.1415,
2657,
753,
8567,
24972 --
-- 85871, 25871
3928, 5657,
2592, 5624.
(aplausos)
¿podemos cortar este pedazo de música, por favor?
Ahora, quisiera hablar un poco acerca del calentamiento global
Volviendo a 1968
podemos ver el rango de la montaña de Brokeback Mountain
estaba cubierto por 151 pulgadas de una capa de nieve.
Entre paréntesis, allá en las laderas,
y quiero mostrarles ese hombre negro esquiando.
(risas)
pero pasando los años,
10 años despues, se erosionaron las capas de nieve
y, si se dan cuenta, los arboles comienzan a volverse amarillos
el nivel del agua ha comenzado a secarse.
Unos años más adelante, no había nieve que quedase.
y esos árboles se volvieron cafés,
Este año, desafortunadamente la cama del lago
se torno en un terreno absolutamente roto y seco
Y yo temo, que si no se hace nada por el planeta,
en 20 años, se verá como esto.
(risas)
Sr. Vice presidente, quisiera saber cómo sacarlo a usted.
(aplausos)
Muchas gracias.